what is up think marketing fam man in
this video we need to talk because we're
living through a super crazy time in the
world right now a global pandemic and so
first and foremost I just want to say I
hope you're doing well I hope that your
family that whether you've been laid off
you're working from home or whether
things are great that you're just
hanging in there in this season and I
wanted to do a video specifically to
help you as a reminder this channel is
all about really the best tips and
strategies for how to market and build
your business whether you want to build
a personal brand your social media
aspiring influencer you want to figure
out how to make money from home or
whether you're an entrepreneur a service
provider and you're trying to say man
how do I use YouTube and LinkedIn and
Facebook and Instagram to get more leads
to build my influence to build a strong
brand that can weather the storm so let
me know how you're doing if you happen
to be here live Michael it's good to see
you dr. Greta it's good to see Alina
Lilly good to see you thanks for being
here if you're on the replay here's what
our topic is today I've got a quick case
study to share with you that I think is
really important right now in the midst
of crisis and let me know if what's
happening what's happening on the ground
where you're at what's happening in your
world tell me in the comments and we
have some announcements about the think
marketing podcast is way as well as a
way for you if you want to go deeper
with us to actually jump on the phone
and connect with someone from the think
media team and so first and foremost
thank you for being a subscriber to the
think marketing podcast a new episode
out today let me know where you listen
from I hope that you've seen that were
over on Spotify we're on 13 episodes
y'all started at the beginning of the
year and we're on Apple of course iTunes
Google where's your preferred place to
listen of course YouTube right and you
can catch the video podcast or the audio
podcast here as well if you're like me I
use YouTube red and I love YouTube but I
do a lot of times I started playing and
then I do some chores or going to walk
or do whatever
and I listen to YouTube content with my
phone on silent but here's what we're
gonna do you know in the midst of geez
what is talking about could be a global
recession you know I'm coming to you
from Las Vegas and by the way we do a
monthly online meetup now called Vegas
influencers com if you haven't heard
about that just go to Vegas influencers
com
but they've already said the strip is
shut down the hotels are shut down we
are in the perfect storm of having
restaurants travel people all laid off
as many as 400,000 people almost approx
laid off our economy's getting hit hard
already and so there's never really been
a more important time I think to lean in
and become creative to think about how
you can pivot and to think about not how
you can profit from a pandemic we never
want to exploit this or be opportunistic
but we have to figure out how to profit
during a pandemic during a recession how
can we serve people while still actually
building our businesses how can we grow
our subscribers and get views out of a
heart of service during this time so
very soon I'm gonna be recording some
episodes for you so my the reason we
need to talk is I need you to ask some
questions but here's what I'm looking
for you can ask some simple questions
I'm gonna do an AMA ask me anything on
the podcast I'm gonna record those this
week and then those are gonna be rolling
out to help you in this time but what
I'm asking for is as deep as you want to
go I'm gonna pick out some questions
where you at where are you stuck if you
can tell me what your niche is if you
can tell me what your business is if you
could tell me what your goals are and if
you could tell me what your question is
that I'm gonna be able to be more
specific to basically give you some
coaching and some strategy on what I
would do so if you've got a question you
can post that if you have to be here in
the live chat make sure to put like four
questions before it and after it but
most of you gonna probably be watching
on the replay post it right below this
video and we're gonna do some very
special ask me anything to really get
granular and specific how do you build
an email list right now how do you get
notice and stand out on social right now
how do you actually make money right now
what are the best affiliate but whatever
you whatever you need help with and if
you're just starting that's cool too
maybe you want to narrow down or get
clarity between a couple different
things this is your chance to ask your
question Darren's got a great question
is now a good time to launch a course
and so if you can see in the live chat
or if you're on the replay post it below
throw up a couple question marks and
drop those good to see you Darren by the
way what up coach Jimmy in the house
Cody great to see hey second thing that
I wanted to share with you is just a
quick encouragement of how powerful I
think it is if we pivot during this time
look businesses have been disrupted one
of the hardest hit businesses is in the
states where they're shutting down
non-essential businesses and they're
shutting down restaurants and now the
epicenter of this thing is in New York
but it started in Seattle and one of my
favorite restaurants is called Canlis
and I've only actually eaten there one
time two times I guess because it's a
fine-dining restaurant right like it's
easy to spend $400 on a meal and my
cousins worked there and they took Sony
and I there when we were just first
getting married but of course their
restaurant got shut down and they had to
pivot and I want to share this story
with you because I want you to be
thinking about how can you pivot your
YouTube channel your business your
strategy your products your offering and
they said this times are changing it for
now so where we were shutting our down
our dining room and we're gonna bring
the food to you I've seen a lot of
restaurants just closed their doors and
just closed all they're doing is in
Vegas right now they're just losing
money just blues and money their team's
laid off and and I get it but how can
you adapt and pivot so I was so inspired
because out of this pandemic and
recession they launched three big
businesses the first is the bagel shed
little breakfast thing second is Canlis
drive-through and third is Canlis family
meal and they said starting on Monday
we're closing our restaurant and we're
open three in its place a breakfast
bagel shed a burger drive-through for
lunch and a family meal dinner
service fine-dining is not what Seattle
needs right now instead this is one idea
for safely creating jobs for our
employees while serving as much of the
city as we can we got this Seattle and I
just love this attitude and spirit
because then you see that here they are
in the war room with the team they're
like here's our management team in the
war room as we prepare to wind down one
restaurant and open up three more and
and they're just figuring out how
they're gonna do it like how they're
gonna pivot how are you gonna pivot in
this time and if you need help that's
why I'm asking for your questions
because myself had they're tourists that
think media team we're gonna be here to
help you and then I love seeing this
launch the line is crazy as they launch
this menu and this is not fine-dining
anymore now they got burger and fries 14
bucks you got that citrus soda four
dollars right pivoting and adapting to
the situation here they said look we're
gonna sell out in a few minutes if
you're already in line don't head our
way because we are literally selling
out in the midst of recession and famine
they're still profiting and prospering
because they made a strategic pivot and
here's the bagel spot this looks way
different than the business I know man
but they're willing to throw up a tent
throw up a little painted sign get their
team out there and serve some bagels
right you know they're they're willing
to do the family meals and deliver them
at night they're willing to do something
different think differently look they
even did a live stream online Canlis
comm /p a know so that while they're
delivering those meals to your home you
can kind of get that fine dining
ambience with the piano and I love this
story because it makes me think
different look it's not problem-free
they've got people like hey actually the
drive-thru goes like this do not try to
sneak in from the left and the right
right here right so so even in the midst
of adapting and pivoting they still have
to you know deal with issues and
challenges but here's a picture of their
you know delivery meal dropping off a
bottle of wine here's the delivery you
know a picture dude I need that bagel
right now man I haven't had breakfast
yet like that's looking amazing but how
does this apply to you times are still
changing and you know we're still now
we're doing Canlis csa up
a box delivery service that's like a
fourth business that they launched and
so I wanted to share that with you
because I know some of you you might be
doing great some of you might really be
struggling right now and we've read a
stat recently that content consumption
social media consumption is exploding up
over 60% you may have saw that that
zooms stock the zoom teleconferencing
service has gone up almost 30 percent in
the last month why because people are
moving online people are consuming more
content people on their phones more
they're looking for hope they're looking
for encouragement they're looking for
answers to problems they're looking for
answers to specific questions now is
your time more than ever for think
marketing to think different about your
marketing to think different and to go
all-in on YouTube social media live
streaming and we're here to help and so
I need your questions we're gonna be I'm
gonna be answering those this week so
throw up some details throw up a couple
question marks around those questions
and then I also want to say that some of
you you've been listening to the podcast
thank you by the way for subscribing for
liking the video if you want to like
this video smash like for you know
turning on notifications if you haven't
done that yet you know make sure you can
just go to the little bell and you can
either get personalized notifications
from YouTube or you can click all
notifications so that way you never miss
when we upload a new episode today is
all about how to stand out and get views
on YouTube by narrowing your niche don't
miss that episode but make sure you
subscribe to the podcast but
specifically you may have heard during
the podcast us talked about some of the
specific ways we can help whether that's
some of our online programs whether
that's some of the live trainings and
coaching that we're doing right now and
weathering you know basically it's this
if you actually would want to jump on
the phone and talk to us about anything
we have a thing called talk with think
calm so if you're wondering specifically
about our courses our events our
coaching programs even in this
particular era if you go to talk with
think calm what you can do is just click
this blue link and you can book a
discovery call you can pick Wednesday
pick a time of the
day and you're gonna jump on with one of
our master coaches that think media you
know all we do is is talk to you find
out more about who you are what your
problems are maybe we can help maybe we
can't that's the point of the call and
if you were specifically wondering man
is this a good idea for my youtube
channel and can I launch that right now
and how can you help whatever I wanted
you to know about those discovery calls
there's there a limited number so make
sure to book that and then show up and
we'll jump on the phone with you that's
talk with think.com and i think there
should be a link in the description down
below or I'll make sure to add that a
little bit later and you can jump on one
of those discovery calls you know other
than that think I see all these great
questions coming in so Constantine
thanks for being here Miranda Astrid
again if you're if you're coming into
this I'm gonna be doing AMA and ask me
anything on the podcast and I'm
recording this week so get your
questions in with as much detail as
possible
astrid says how is the personalized
notifications just when you click the
bell astrid those notifications YouTube
will kind of based on your viewing
behavior recommend and give you some
notifications from think marketing if
you select all you'll get all
notifications from think marketing so if
we draw up a new podcast and we've got
some other new trainings come and in
fact in two weeks we're gonna be doing a
new show with Heather and Melissa Caputo
and myself
that's gonna be fun where we're actually
gonna be doing more Q&A again we're in
your corner in this time we need to
stand together we need to think outside
of the box we need to be creative and
we've you know been in this industry for
a long time been preaching about
live-streaming about video about getting
your tech right your strategy right your
titles right your thumbnails right how
do you do all these things of content
marketing and content creation that
builds your business while serving
people and fulfilling your mission you
know if you're a Purpose Driven leader
that's probably why you're a part of
this podcast and so we're here to help a
lot of things coming your way
and and then finally I just want to say
I appreciate you on behalf of Heather
Omar Nolan Toni come on the whole think
media team we got new content coming
your way I hope you're safe and you know
this thing might resolve sooner or it
might take a long time so either way
we're gonna be here in your corner
helping in every way possible and so get
your question in sign up a talk with
think comm if you are interested in that
make sure you got notifications turned
on for some of the new shows in addition
to the weekly video podcasts come in
here subscribe on the other you know or
audio or ever you want to subscribe and
then if you haven't checked it out yet
definitely watch this next just click or
tap the screen to watch the new podcast
out today on how to stand out and get
noticed to get views on YouTube right
now by narrowing your niche just click
or tap the screen and I'll see you in
that video appreciate you think
marketing community welcome to the pink
marketing show the number one podcast
for growing and scaling your business
with online video i'm heather torres and
i'm shawn kennel and we're from thank me